this video is sponsored by skillshare
have you ever wanted to
do something anything really i'm talking
creatively have you ever wanted to i
don't know
draw or run a successful instagram page
or make
youtube videos or act or write or
increase your productivity in general
well take it from me
the first step to doing something you've
always wanted to do
is knowing how to do it and skillshare
is the best way
to know it's an online learning
community filled with millions of
creative and curious people just like
you and me
that focuses on providing its community
with thousands of inspiring video
classes for less than 10 bucks a month
on their annual sub
the online streaming nature of the
platform means that you can easily watch
and learn
literally anywhere you want at any time
you want with new premium classes being
added all the time and
absolutely no ads ever personally i've
been really enjoying the class called
youtube success
script shoot and edit by marcus brownlee
and if you've seen my recent content on
the channel you now know where i got my
inspiration from
and the best part of all of this is my
first 1000 subscribers to use
my link in the description will receive
a free trial of skillshare premium
membership so
take my advice do something today you
didn't do yesterday
and try skillshare and now on to the
video
hello everyone bandit here have you ever
wondered who would win in a fight
ling from the legend of zelda or
scorpion from mortal kombat
who would combo the other into
non-existence and claim the final fatal
blow and finish their opponent
well i have so i made a video about it
these two mascots of their franchises
are both extremely
famous powerhouses but let's give them
each a brief introduction just in case
on the one hand we have the skillful
swordsman from hyrule named link
the slayer of countless monstrous
abominations the savior of all life
and part-time professional napper on the
other hand we have the ninja from beyond
named scorpion
the master of martial arts the raging
fire demon and leader of the shirai ryu
clan
since the chances of these two ever
appearing in a game together or being
seen in combat of the mortal degree
are slim to none we're going to be
settling this score
theoretically and let me explain the
ground rules both of these characters
have had multiple iterations that
changed up their abilities significantly
with links ranging from being a literal
9 or 10 year old wielding a knife in a
slingshot to a farmhand skateboarding
teenager with a ball and chain
and scorpions ranging from an undead
specter to
well okay he's still basically the same
thing but his moveset and weapons have
been altered over the years as well
because of this i think it's going to be
much simpler to just use
one iteration each for comparison and to
be fair
we'll be using the two most recent
in-game iterations of both characters
link from breath of the wild and
scorpion from mortal kombat 11.
lastly the theoretical combat will be
grouped into five categories of speed
agility strength abilities and weapons
slash
gadgets which we will rank into
numerically valued units and then
simply compare the numbers to determine
a winner for each category okay that's
all the rules and real quick before we
begin
i just wanted to humbly ask that as you
watch this video you would consider
leaving a like if you enjoy the content
and subscribing if you haven't already
for
much much more about eighty percent of
all of my viewers are unsubscribed so
each click means the world to me
and now without further ado fight
category 1 speed most fans of either
series will automatically think about
the lightning-fast reflexes that both
characters are capable of
but in this video reflexes are going to
be determined in the agility category
what i'm talking about here is
essentially if both of these characters
were to sprint against one another in a
hundred meter dash
which one would win let's start with the
hero of the wilds this is probably the
easiest thing to determine in this
entire list about lynx since you can
literally sprint in-game any time you
want at the cost of stamina giving us
simple repeatable reliable data so let's
measure his sprint speed the most common
consensus of link's height in breath of
the wild is about 170 centimeters tall
or just about 5.6 feet
now if we take his height as a unit of
measurement and measure out
say 10 link heights or about 17 meters
we can then time link's sprint across
that distance and come up with our
number
i did this a couple times for accuracy
and came up with an average time of 2.5
seconds
putting this in an understandable unit
of time we can safely say that at a
sprint
link can travel about 6.8 meters per
second or
just about 15.2 miles per hour all
things considered that's a pretty good
sprint speed he's got going there
now let's talk about scorpion it's going
to be a bit more difficult to determine
his speed since we never really see him
just dead sprint in the game
he mostly just kind of shuffles around
and dodges stuff
but one of his abilities is a dash move
and while it is an ability used for
attacking i'm going to list it here
since it does actually
increase his speed and it makes more
sense to talk about the speed
aspect of abilities here than in the
actual ability category
using the same method that we did for
link and judging distance traveled over
time
again i recorded multiple times just to
be safe and came up with 4.14 meters
traveled in just about
.37 seconds which equates to a speed of
about 11.2 meters per second
or just about 25 miles per hour now i
know it might not seem fair to compare a
supernatural dash ability from scorpion
to link's base
unaltered speed value but in a fight
things are not always fair
link doesn't have any speed enhancing
abilities in breath of the wild so
if scorpion wanted to run him down
according to this data and just going
off the fact that he's a trained ninja
he probably could
category 1 goes to scorpion
category 2 agility as i mentioned
earlier this is also going to be a
judgment of speed but in regards to the
character's ability to thoughtfully
react
or attack starting with link again
breath of the wild introduced us to a
link that's quicker than any we've seen
before when playing the game if link is
able to dodge an attack at just the
right moment
time slows down around him and he's able
to not only dodge but also move to his
opponent and deliver
multiple blows all within the fraction
of a single second this effect also
happens when he's readying an arrow in
the air
according to a video from nintendo black
crisis link is able to
physically react when time itself is
moving about 19 times slower than normal
meaning if he's able to visibly strike
seven times in what we the players
perceive as
3.2 seconds in reality which would be 19
times faster he's actually striking
seven
times in about .17 seconds or at a speed
of about 41 strikes in a whole second
this is absolutely terrifying but
there's a catch
in either circumstance according to what
we see in game link
has to be in the middle of either
dodging a blow or falling in mid air
in other words link is not shown to be
able to just turn this speed shifting
ability on and off at will
it seems to be related to how intense of
a situation he's in
you might call this adrenaline which is
a legitimate reaction that all humans
have to intense situations
and while link's adrenaline reaction to
intensity may be unparalleled and just
downright terrifying it does appear to
be at least somewhat circumstantial
however for this category we'll use the
unit of strikes per second to determine
agility
so link tallies in at 41. now scorpion
is pretty quick
too he is literally a master of ninjutsu
which revolves around the ability to
react to
incoming attacks and in some of the
comic books he's shown capable of
seemingly delivering multiple strikes at
the same point
in time but that's a comic book one
that's not the same scorpion i mentioned
we'd be using for this consideration
and two it's a comic book the action
shots you see
in the pictures are largely debatable
because the artists try to capture so
much in a single moment
according to the in-game combat he's
quick and could possibly launch
four or even five attacks in the span of
a single second
especially when punching or using his
katana after dashing or teleporting but
let's give scorpion the biggest
overestimate we could and assume he can
launch
six complete thought out attacks in a
single second
as anyone can already see we're not
shown in game with any of his moves that
he's anywhere near the capacity of hits
per second that link is
link is nearly 7 times quicker and even
though it's directly related to his
adrenaline rush and whether or not he's
dodging an attack
if you think about it attacks are
literally what fights are made of so
yeah category 2 goes to link category 3
strength this is pretty self-explanatory
we'll be judging the biggest feats of
strength we can see
either character pull off in game and
comparing the two now link was gnarly in
the last category and in this one he's
yet again
pretty gnarly you see even though link
is shown to be able to push
large boulders that realistically would
weigh somewhere around 18
000 pounds or even though he's shown to
be able to chop fully grown trees down
in two swings that's still not the
strongest thing he does
in game according to a video from celtic
the strongest thing that link literally
accomplishes in game is deflecting
attacks with his left arm which means
that link not only meets the oncoming
attack with
similar force but pushes the attack
backwards with greater force
rendering it useless this is something
that link is able to do by his strength
alone and not his equipment as proven by
the fact that he can deflect an attack
with any equipped shield
according to zeltick who did some
fabulous calculations on the matter
link is able to exert 448
000 newtons of force when he's
deflecting a lionel's charge
and that's pretty darn strong now let's
talk about scorpion's feats of strength
he can easily lift grown adults off the
ground with an extended arm can
easily break his opponent's bones and
rip off multiple limbs multiple times in
combat albeit through the use of his
weaponry but his strongest feat that i
can tell
is probably the fact that he with a
single leg can kick an opponent who in
some cases weighs upwards of 400 pounds
a good 30 feet away in less than a
second
i would say it's his spine ripping
brutality but
i'm not even sure how to calculate that
since the spinal cord shouldn't even
come out completely like that without
breaking up the neck
like visa showed us in this very
educational video on the topic
since there are several assumptions i'd
have to be making about the human body
especially with the angle that this is
happening at
i honestly don't even know where to
start with calculating how much force
that would require
so let's calculate how much force that
deadly kick would require
assuming scorpion is facing his heaviest
in-game foe
xiao khan who according to this wiki
page weighs 181 kilograms or 400 pounds
for scorpion to send shao khan off the
ground approximately 30 feet away in
approximately 0.4 seconds means that his
one leg exerted a force of about
10 400 newtons or 2
300 pounds with a single leg this is
further proven by the fact that he can
routinely crack human bones with his
kicks and punches which on average
require a force of about 4
000 newtons to break if this guy drop
kicked you with both legs it would
literally feel like being hit by a tesla
model s
at maximum acceleration he's clearly a
very lethal
very capable very strong fighter but
again the difference in performance
between the two is simply staggering
link's one arm can exert over 40 times
the amount of force that scorpion's leg
can
category's three winner is once again
link
category 4 abilities now this is where
things are going to get interesting and
we can start to really focus on what
makes these characters unique
it's also very hard to judge numerically
which character has the better abilities
so we're gonna use the tried and true
method called common sense
as far as breath of the wild link is
concerned food and armor buffs aside his
four abilities are
daruk's protection which is a triple
charge impenetrable shield herbosa's
fury
a triple charge area of effect lightning
strike mifa's grace
a single charge resurrection and the
rito's gale a triple charge whirlwind
that grants link a very tall
jump i know i know the last one's
actually called rivali's gail but what
can i say i have to pick on that jerk
chicken every now and then
now scorpion on the other hand has more
than just four abilities
most obviously he can teleport short
distances in an
instant such as behind an opponent and
leave behind him a solidified after
image which can prove to be
very confusing to his opponent he can
throw fireballs at people
he can breathe fire on people he can
turn into his fire skeleton form and
dash at extreme speeds as mentioned
previously he can hurl opponents to the
ground from the air using demon fire
and of course he is a literal undead
wraith who has routinely returned to
life across the entirety of the series's
lore
comparing the two and starting with link
dyrix protection is useful
until its charges are spent urbosa's
fury is a possible game changer but
only if link is able to charge it up
beforehand which is something scorpion
is more than capable of preventing with
his speed and ranged attacks mifa's
grace will give link
one possible do-over and rivali's gail
could be useful for creating distance
and an opening for arrow fire
but again is unlikely to be useful
against scorpion due to its charge-up
period and it also leaves links
susceptible to scorpion's aerial
takedown ability
scorpion's teleport is something that is
uncountable if used properly
especially with his after image that
would confuse link's senses and reflexes
his fireballs would be probably easily
deflected by link's shield
or even his sword his fire breath can
also be defended against
by link's hylian shield his fire dash
would enable him to close distances
between himself and link very quickly
and since he can grab his opponent
in the dash it could prove to be quite
the deadly ability
using the powers of common sense since
link's one
real offensive ability urbosa's fury
would most likely not be able to be used
due to its charge a period
and his distancing ability rivali's gail
would open him up to a deadly takedown
and also requires another charge-up
period
and his two remaining abilities aren't
very offensive
common sense dictates that scorpion's
teleportation
after images and fire dash give the
ability advantage
to scorpion so category 4 goes to
scorpion
category 5 weapons and gadgets as you
can tell i've saved the best category
not only for last but also as the
tiebreaker between the two
so first up link for his weapons we're
going to assume that he's using his
classic combo of the master sword
coupled with the hylian shield
and we're going to assume that neither
of them are going to break in combat
the master sword is an extremely
powerful blade blessed with the power to
repel evil and can shoot out laser beams
when link is on full health
the hylian shield is nigh impenetrable
and large enough to provide
optimal protection from attacks for his
bow and arrows his
bow really doesn't matter as there's no
one specific bow he canonically receives
in the game but he can
shoot out regular arrows fire arrows ice
arrows bomb arrows shock arrows and
ancient arrows as for his gadgets we
will include the abilities on his chica
slate
so the bombs stasis cryonis and magnesis
all of his chica abilities are energy
based and seemingly limitless with
recharge periods the bombs explode on
command rather than on impact
stasis is useful in literally freezing
enemies in place for a period of time
magnesius could be used to steal weapons
that are made of metal
and cryonis isn't really useful in this
fight actually
now onto scorpion his most famous weapon
is the spear
which is actually a kunai attached to
the end of a rope or chain
he uses this attack in swinging motions
circling the weapons around his body in
a perfect combination of both defense
and
offense he also uses it to grapple his
opponents by throwing it at them
stabbing them and pulling them towards
himself while yelling get over here
he also carries two katanas called
ninjato with which he is extremely
proficient in melee bouts he can also
use his fire abilities to raise the heat
of
any of his weapons to the point that
they are glowing red and move through
human flesh almost effortlessly his
final weapon would be
his own body since he is extremely
skillful and a master of multiple forms
of martial arts
he's also been fighting at the highest
levels for most of his existence so his
skill is multiplied by years of
experience and a deep knowledge on how
to kill
to be honest with you looking at both of
them the matchup of their weapons and
gadgets is
pretty even on paper since both
characters could counter or block most
of the others moves in some way
ultimately it's going to come down to
how the weapons and gadgets are used
so for this category we'll actually have
to look at all the previous ones and use
that data to determine the grand winner
and you know what that means
it's time for a theoretical battle
scenario let's say the opponents meet in
a field
pyrofield why not link could open the
fight with bombs or arrows or his sword
beams
but scorpion would be able to evade
these attacks with teleportation and by
dashing towards link quicker than link
could sprint away to close the distance
quickly
alternatively scorpion could attempt to
shell link with fireballs
but link would simply deflect them with
either his sword or his shield
all the while closing the distance
between the two either way the fight
would escalate to melee range very
quickly as neither opponent would be
able to be felt by ranged attacks
meaning link's arrows and bombs are
rendered useless
scorpion's finesse and martial art
skills would enable him to throw attacks
at link in ways and combinations that
the hero has never
seen before such as fire breath
alongside a katana slice or a circular
spear attack that's so hot it could melt
the hylian shield upon impact
this would prevent link from using his
offensive abilities and force him to
either dodge or block with his trusty
shield or use daruk's protection and be
on the defensive trying to study the
moves coming at him
link would attempt to retaliate with
slashes from his own sword but
these basic swings would most likely be
clearly picked up on by the more
experienced opponent and deflected or
just dodged entirely
scorpion would continue his onslaught
preventing link from using his special
abilities like stasis
and would soon attempt to deliver a
fatality by breaking through the young
hero's defenses and teleporting behind
link leaving a discombobulating after
image in front of his opponent
but after the ninja appears behind link
and lunges towards the hero's back
to finish him he realizes too late that
he made one fatal mistake
to put simply he threatened link's life
you see
all link needs is a fraction of a second
to catch on to the facade and
immediately he views the world around
him 19
times slower meaning scorpion's teleport
would look something like this
to link while link can still move like
this
for this kind of reaction there is no
defense
link in his blinding reaction speed
would simply do what he's done
over and over again in game dodge move
in and deliver
a finishing blow using 400 000
newtons of force from his arm that's
right i've gone over the fight many
times on paper and no matter what the
setting is
i just can't see a way that scorpion
could get around link's terrifying
reaction speed up close
especially since if scorpion uses the
teleportation and successfully kills
link once
link could return immediately with
mifa's grace and scorpion's
teleportation would be
unlikely to work a second time now that
link knows what's going on with ranged
combat out of the picture and scorpion's
best moves and attacks counterable by
link's extreme reaction speed and nearly
impenetrable defenses it looks like the
one who's finished
is scorpion
[Music]
but that's just my theory what did you
guys think is scorpion from mortal
kombat 11 more deadly than what i
depicted in this video or do you think
this is pretty spot on
let me know in the comments below also
thank you so much for watching
please consider leaving a like if you're
still watching at this point and also
subscribing if you haven't yet
big welcome to thomas d who recently
joined the ranks of my bandit crew
if you're interested in joining up and
helping my videos come to life
feel free to check that join button
below or the links to my patreon and
merch in the description
also down there are links to my twitter
and instagram so follow me there as well
that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day
this is mask nintendo bandit signing out
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you